are the two HGTV stars though feuding uh
more reality drama the story is false at
least at least according to flip or flop
star Christina Musa she's slamming
rumors over reportedly having a beef
with fellow HDTV HDTV star what's going
on with you guys today it's early it's
early Joanna Gaines yeah so Christina
took to Instagram to set the record
straight by posting this this article
from In Touch magazine saying quote what
a load of BS I've never commented on a
tabloid ever and have swallowed a lot of
expletive from these tabloids hash tag
In Touch magazine this is disgusting I
have always been a huge supporter of
female entrepreneurs she has been and
this is what I hate seeing something
like this like pitting two powerful
women against each other there's room
for everyone at the table whether it's
with HGTV or with another network which
is what we're seeing Joanna Gaines do
now that she's returning to TV she just
announced earlier this month it's just
it's sickening to you know just see just
because they're both on TV just because
they're affiliated with the same network
does not mean that there's bad blood but
there's beef right and people I mean you
can people take any element of their
existence she's a blonde she's a
brunette let's make this a thing but you
you know Cassie you are a huge a huge
champion and you champion the notion of
a female empowerment and girl power it's
something I always say and eats he
actually talked to Christina at her home
I believe it was last year where she was
very positive and she's all about girl
power take a look honestly for me I just
sort of you know take things day by day
and I don't I don't overthink things
like this I'm just excited to be doing
it it's fun I have a lot of exciting
things coming up it's just awesome
because like it's like right now all my
girlfriends are like we're all kind of
doing the whole like entrepreneur girl
power things first of all what she's
saying is on the money in two sometimes
you always have to consider the source
of where these BS rumors are coming from
and since we are about girl power let's
show them a little support make sure you
guys watch Christina al-mu so season
eight was just renewed for a flip or
flop and Joanna Gaines will be back on
your TV - she's a with her own net
so take back your taters everyone
[Music]
[Applause]